THE WORLD WAS AT MY FEET.
I EVEN INVENTED
MY OWN SIGNATURE MOVE--
THE REX ROCKET!
[grunts]
- OH, MY GOD!
THAT WAS AMAZING!
- I HAD LEGIONS OF FANS
WHO ADORED ME.
- COULD YOU MAKE IT OUT
TO DUKE?
YOU'RE MY HERO, REX.
I WANT TO BE JUST LIKE YOU
WHEN I GROW UP.
- WHAT ARE YOU, SEVEN?
- I'M ONLY SIX.
- SIX INCHES?
NOT ENOUGH CABLE, SON.
YOU'LL NEVER MAKE IT
IN PORN.
STAY IN SCHOOL.
- OHH.
- OH, I WAS ON TOP
OF THE WORLD,
BUT I FLEW TOO CLOSE
TO THE SUN.
[snorts]
I BURNED OUT.
COULDN'T DO WHAT I, UH,
NEEDED TO DO.
OH, BOY.
I'M--I'M REALLY EMBARRASSED
ABOUT THIS, FOLKS.
WELL, ONE MINUTE.
OH, BROTHER.
I'M THINKING OF EVERYTHING.
SORRY, GUYS.
I KNOW THIS SEEMS
UNPROFESSIONAL,
BUT MAYBE YOU GUYS
CAN HIT CRAFT SERVICE.
OH, OH,
STARTING TO GET A TINGLE.
NO! SHIT! IT'S GONE!
COME ON, COME ON!
MY PRESENCE IN PORN FILMS
WAS REDUCED TO NON-SEXUAL
CHARACTER ROLES,
LIKE THE POOL BOY'S BOSS
AND ONE OF THE STUDENTS
NOT KEPT AFTER CLASS.
IT FLUNG ME INTO
A DEEP DEPRESSION.
[crying]
[lid pops]
[snorts]
HUH?
WHAT ARE ALL YOU PEOPLE
DOING IN MY BATHROOM?
[thud]
FORTUNATELY, UNCLE SAM
STRAIGHTENED ME OUT.